des images choquantes des trous de balle
dans la façade d'une garderie de l'est
de montréal un rappel du danger que
représentent les armes à feu selon
justin trudeau heureusement personne n'a
été blessé
elle aurait pu être tragique l'entrée en
matière du premier ministre le jour du
dépôt de projets de loi majeurs sur le
contrôle des armes au pays le
gouvernement trudeau annonce un gel
national des armes de poing dès
l'automne aujourd'hui on va de l'avant
avec un projet de loi qui va faire en
sorte qu'il ne sera plus possible
d'acheter de vendre de transférer ou
d'importer des armes de poing au canada
une mesure pour éviter que 55 mille
armes s'ajoutent chaque année à celles
qui sont déjà en circulation
les propriétaires qui détiennent
légalement des armes de poing pourront
les conserver ottawa interdit aussi les
chargeurs de plus de 5 cartouches pour
les armes des pôles et prévoit des
peines maximales plus sévère pour le
trafic d'armes passant de 10 à 14 ans de
prison nous savons que pour réduire
l'accès aux armes à feu est légal
nous devons réduire le trafic d'armes à
nos frontières ottawa veut aussi
s'attaquer à la violence familiale en
facilitant la saisie d'armes d'une
personne menaçante pour son entourage
après des années de combat pour le
contrôle des armes cette survivante de
polytechnique parle d'une étape
importante
spécialement le gel touchant les armes
de poing on assume notre responsabilité
en annonçant un gel donc robinet est
fermé c'est historique on n'a jamais
assisté à ça que le gouvernement se
décide enfin la mairesse de montréal
aimerait qu'ottawa allait encore plus
loin
valérie plein est écrit nous espérons
que le pas franchi aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement canadien nous mène vers
l'interdiction complète des armes de
poing sur notre territoire et hors de la
portée des jeunes
déjà les militants pro armes promettent
de s'adresser aux tribunaux pour
contester la loi c'est vraiment une
attaque frontale kanté propriétaires
d'armes à feu contre la possession
légale des armes à feu et c'est quelque
chose que ça pensera peau et c'est
quelque chose qu'ils vont qui vont payer
pour politiquement dans les prochaines
années d'ici l'entrée en vigueur de la
loi il prévoit que des acheteurs pour se
ruer sur les items bientôt interdite
c'est sûr et certain que les ventes dans
deux points et deux chargeurs déjà
existants vont sans exploser c'est
évident aux yeux des conservateurs c'est
l'idéologie qui guide le gouvernement
ait pas la sécurité publique mais je
pense que au lieu de consacrer autant de
ressources compte les honnêtes citoyens
qui possèdent des armes à feu le
gouvernement devrait consacrer plus de
ressources à lutter contre les gangs de
rue à lutter contre le trafic des armes
illégales les libéraux eux parlent d'eux
jour historique la mesure la plus
importante prise au canada en matière de
violence armée depuis une génération
un autre volet important du contrôle des
armes se fait toujours attendre ottawa
promet que son programme de rachat
obligatoire pour les armes d'assaut sera
en vigueur d'ici la fin de l'année mais
le gouvernement trudeau doit aussi
trouver une façon d'empêcher que les
fusils interdit soit aussitôt remplacés
par de nouveaux modèles ici louis blouin
radio canada